So far we've been focusing
on defending ourselves, but
we know that the attacks
come from malicious actors.
Are there ways that allow us to go
after these malicious actors and
have consequences for them?
Well, one way to do that is to have laws
that govern illegal online activity.
In this lesson, we're going to talk
about cyber laws that address these and
some of the issues that are related
to intellectual property and
its protection.
And then we're going to talk about,
what is considered ethical behavior
when it comes to our online activities?
In the second half of the lesson,
we're going to focus on online privacy.
In particular, we're going to address,
how information about our online
activities can be captured by others?
How can they use it?
Who can they share it with?
And, what kind of options do we have
in controlling each one of these?